all right everybody let's jump into this
first story so we have this tweet from
at remarks on twitter Justin this is
from yesterday night around 6 23 pm
Ukraine Ukraine's President zelenski
says U.S will have to send their sons
and daughters the same way we are
sending our sons and daughters to War
and what I love about this is yes he
said it yes it's confirmed but of course
they're panicking and they're uh look at
this fact check from AP News
zielinski didn't say here's what AP says
zielinski didn't say U.S troops needed
to fight in Ukraine that's weird that's
actually what he did say he did say that
so here's here's the framing they're
going with
claim a video clip shows Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski saying that
Americans want to send their sons and
daughters to the war in Ukraine
ap's assessment missing context zelenski
was explaining that if Russia attacked
NATO member states which are U.S allies
the U.S would likely send troops to
protect those countries he was not
suggesting Americans would have to fight
in Ukraine right because it's going to
be in Poland that the U.S troops are in
Poland and they'll never go into Ukraine
there will be no advancement on that
front once the U.S pushes Russia out of
Poland and then Russia is occupying
Ukraine the US of course would just be
like we are done supporting this war
Ukraine is lost of course because
because that's what he certainly meant
they say the clip cut from a two-hour
live stream news conference on the
somber one year anniversary of Russia's
somber come on guys show zelenski
speaking with the audio dubbed by a
translator quote
the U.S will have to send their sons and
daughters exactly the same way as we are
sending their sons and daughters to war
our sons no he said they are sons and
dice very weird quote right and they
will have to fight because it's NATO
that that we're talking about and they
will be dying God forbid because it's a
horrible thing so what he's basically
saying is with the fact check in mind
when the U.S is dragged into World War
III over their country that is not a
NATO Ally then we'll have to send our
children to die in Europe oh okay why on
Earth would we send people to defend
Europe if it's going to be a nuclear war
if it's the U.S versus Russia we can die
in the U.S just as easily as we can you
know died in nuclear fire in the US as
easily as we could die in a nuclear fire
in the uh in Europe I think there's no
reason for the for the U.S to send
people to Europe in a nuclear war I'm
not even convinced necessarily it'll be
nuclear I think the moment we send
troops to Europe a whole bunch of oil
refinery just explode all at once
there's gonna be cyber attacks power
plants will shut down the grid will go
on go out I I I would imagine
that when it comes to cyber War it's a
Mexican standoff and every country has
their finger on the button to destroy
another country's infrastructure the
crazy thing is that when we started
developing the internet and then we
hooked everything into it without the
thought of security we basically built
towers of of sticks of bamboo and we are
we built our cities on top of bamboo and
it's like you know it's holding us up
like Bamboo's not it's pretty great you
can make scaffolding out of it but it's
really easy to knock down because it's
not that strong and every country is
built on top of it so you don't need a
nuke they can just type in some press
enter and whoosh
I think internet goes out I think well I
mean I think that you're probably right
and I think that that only adds to my
point that there there is no longer the
fight over Lane over European land the
way that uh the way that zelinski's
framing it if you are talking about a
you know fifth generational Warfare or
whatever
fifth generational
like psychological operations and stuff
well I I yeah that I think that's the
kind of stuff that would be used
especially if you're talking about you
know all-out War if you're talking about
nuclear war as well there's I just don't
see Americans needing to hold European
uh land you know I don't see Americans
need to to go into Europe in in a you
know type of War you know you know you
know it got me really on board with
voting for Trump this next time around
it's that video from uh the whatever
podcast I don't know if you all have
seen those clips that are going viral
where he gets these low-wit narcissistic
women to talk about their views on
things and I'm just watching the the
clip of that woman talk about feminism
and why she's a feminist and her
inability to articulate any kind of
coherent thought
and then I just thought about it and I
was like
is this why we have the Petro dollar
is this is this why we have the Federal
Reserve are we bombing kids in in Yemen
and Syria and other countries so that
these vapid narcissistic women can have
cheap products to smear on their faces
you know I'm ready to go back and work
the farm I'm I'm ready to just get back
to chopping wood and working really hard
and and these luxuries are bad for us
the U.S I understand the fear I guess is
probably that China would start crushing
the world with with you know their
ridiculous weird communism and that's
probably that that literally is a bad
thing so okay fine that's a tough
question right there but if is is this
why the U.S does these things like is
the reason we're fighting in Ukraine for
the expansion of energy so that these
vapid narcissistic entitled Millennials
and gen's ears can be as dumb as a box
of rocks but get free stuff the reason
I'm like vote for Trump close the
borders build the factories everybody
start get back to work we're not doing
this anymore you're not getting a free
ride the reason I'm not absolutely out
of my mind enraged about the slavery in
China or in wherever wherever they have
I mean slavery you know Loosely but
where they're building these these these
phones is because I'm getting I'm I'm
Sedated by the technology because I have
access to cheap computers and phones if
I didn't if I wasn't seeing value from
the slavery I'd be out of my mind about
it but instead I'm like you're there's
almost analysis there's also the fact
that that you know there's enough
horrible things that happen every single
day to drive uh someone insane if they
knew about them all like the world is a
big place and there's a lot of people
and there's a lot of suffering so the
the fact that that there's you know
terrible things going on in China and
stuff if you don't have the capacity to
know about it and you you shouldn't
focus on it and that's one of the
reasons why I think that people are
they're just so frequently depressed is
because the internet is delivered
delivering bad news right to their news
feed all day long and they doom scroll
and stuff I think that has a
psychological effect on people
he was asked about polling in the United
States where the opposition to the war
in Ukraine is increasing and he was
asked about Republican lawmakers say
people like MTG Etc who are want
accountability at the very least for
what 120 billion that's going there
so they kind of teed him up for this so
this was part of his rant basically
saying that Republican that Americans
shouldn't have a contrary opinion about
the war that elected officials should
support it a hundred percent and if they
don't this is where this is going what's
interesting is you didn't hear anyone
from the regime say oh no no this is not
where that's headed because this is the
natural escalation you know we've seen
this before so we keep sending more
artillery we're sending Jets who who's
teaching Ukrainian Pilots how to use our
Weaponry we're just just send it with
some instructions I mean this is where
it's headed
so you haven't seen anyone from the
defense department or anyone with the
Biden White House say no that this is
that was totally out of line that's not
going to be the case is this where this
is probably where it's headed I know
that we got a long way to go but I'm
curious your thoughts on what would
happen the day Donald Trump takes office
again with the Ukraine war still in
action do you think he just pulls
everything back like a snap of a finger
you know Tim I think that the more this
goes on and the more it does escalate it
increases Trump's chances of winning I
mean I think this issue alone
could be a winning issue for him
um that and the Border because it's not
going to change but this at where how
this is going directionally this could
be his biggest issue so yes he would
take over I think he learned his lessons
about who he can and can't trust in the
military industrial complex and the
Pentagon which is basically no one
um and so I think if he becomes
president he fires Mark milley and a
whole lot of other people and he
automatically says I'm not listening to
any advice we're done with this I can
already see the political ads that are
going to be running on this channel and
every other YouTube channel it's going
to be a red screen and it's going to
show a trained derailment and there's
going to be some some like somber deep
voice of a 50 year old man who sounds
like he smoked a pack of cigarettes
every day you know since he was 12
saying something like when a trained
derailment spread toxic chemicals
killing livestock and threatening the
lives of millions Joe Biden flew to
Ukraine and then it's going to be like
spending 100 billion dollars of your
money on a country for what reason don't
vote for Joe Biden
probably that day alone could be the
that was it for me at least I agree and
even even you know look I like DeSantis
but even that day was big on like
DeSantis went out of my mind on that one
that's right Donald Trump going down
there giving out Big Macs was just like
I was laughing and it felt good like it
felt humanly good that Donald Trump was
there with a with a smile buying Big
Macs it's like almost stupid but it was
it was human it was something and and
the funny thing is like let me just let
me just say like this Donald Trump went
to East Palestine Biden went to Ukraine
holy are you serious right man look I
mean we don't even know if this guy's
gonna be able to run anyway so maybe
that's it maybe they're just like who
cares yeah it's not going to be him
right
but I think that was his man you know
that's Trump's magic and I mean I I I'm
a DeSantis fan too we spent a lot of
time in Florida
um he just does not have that sort of
personal connection uh that Trump has
honed over years that that comes by him
naturally and that was on display uh in
Ohio uh despite the contrast you know
even if even if Biden uh hadn't uh made
his trip to Ukraine it on its own it
reminds people of what makes made Trump
a special uh president it was a surprise
yeah Biden's like surprise everybody hey
I went to Ukraine and we're like why
walk this line that's amazing to give
him 500 million dollars yeah I remember
500 million to a half a half a billion
dollars
some uh Military Support wow then Janet
Yellen went so but yeah so I'm watching
those videos of these vapid young people
and I'm just thinking about what is this
system that we live in and why do we do
it it's not oh sorry oh no it's just
like we want to maintain the Petro
dollar the United States manufactures
nothing so in order to maintain our GDP
we for one we do produce culture and
spread those movies and music around and
make money off that so there is an
export there but for the most part we
don't manufacture and Export things so
the only reason our economy is propped
up is because we are it's it's a mostly
unipolar world now becoming multi-polar
but that means the United States
controlled everything decimated its
competition and put guns everywhere and
so it's like use the US dollar to buy
oil or else which means when this
country wants to buy oil they need to
buy the dollars from us and we can
charge whatever we want because we got
the guns and then for us we need to
print the dollars and buy the oil how
about that it's sort of like having I've
never had uh like a grandfather that's
super rich he's like the patriarch of
the family and everyone hates him in the
family but he's the one with all the
money why does everyone hate him in just
in such a dick he's such an alcoholic
abusive racist old from way back and
that's what the United States has become
this hated patriarch it's the Vestige of
the military industrial we used to be so
great in the 80s and 70s so great you
know because we were actually we're
pretty happy back then too yeah but we
did prevent world war three before the
invasion
they really hated the Iran Contra thing
was insane
so absolutely so and you know John
Rockefeller he was probably always I
don't know I don't know if he's
personally a jerk but I think you know
you get these weird old Patriarchs that
are like they control all the money in
the family and I feel like that's how
people are just waiting for the United
States to die because you can't kill the
old man that's why I'm saying you vote
for Trump he builds a wall he brings the
factories back he stops the foreign
policy garbage and that means we're not
going to be the global police or
anything like that and that means all of
these vapid young people have to roll up
their sleeves and learn how to chop
wooden and I'm I'm totally fine with
that yeah I don't I think it's good
that's it the gluttony of this country
is a huge problem just there's tons of
really dumb people who don't work and
the reason why we're seeing people
getting degrees in like feminist dance
theory is because you don't have to do
anything it's like you used to have to
break rocks I'm going to be an
influencer yeah that's right when China
asked there was that study that's they
asked Chinese kids you know what do you
want to be when you grow up they're like
astronauts and they asked American kids
in YouTubers or whatever
they wanted to be personalities I think
it's not the luxury that's destroying
people or the even the excessive luxury
it's the lack of relativism to the
luxury if you're born in luxury you
don't know it's a luxury you got to get
out of the system go to South America
and spend some time in the jungle where
if you eat the fruit you're going to get
dysentery and then come back to the
United States and realize that running
water is a godsend I don't think the
fruit gives you dysentery you should
check it out go to bailin it's where
they poop in the river they don't know
that's that's the water not the fruit it
gets into the ground into the into the
soil and then if you eat the fruit that
comes out of it there's parasites and
stuff in it and also it's a different
biome like your body can't handle
certain chemicals the way they can here
um I got real sick eating acai in Brazil
yeah I ate a fruit that's crazy it was
like sweet creamy fruit I'd never eaten
before and I just started puking
immediately after I ate it it was crazy
but it tasted so good thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time